In a lot of our examples, you're going to
see DataCollators popping up over and over.
They're used in both PyTorch and TensorFlow
workflows, and maybe even in JAX, but no-one
really knows what's happening in JAX.
We have a research team working on that, so
maybe they'll tell us soon.
But what are data collators?
Data collators collate data.
More specifically, they put together a list
of samples into a single training minibatch.
For some tasks, the data collator can be very
straightforward.
For example, when you're doing sequence classification,
all you really need from your data collator
is that it pads your samples to the same length
and concatenates them into a single Tensor.
But for other workflows, data collators can
be more complex, as they handle some of the
preprocessing needed for that particular task.
For PyTorch users, you usually pass the DataCollator
to your Trainer object.
In TensorFlow, the easiest way to use a DataCollator
is to pass it to the to_tf_dataset method
of your dataset.
You'll see these approaches used in the examples
and notebooks throughout this course.
In both cases, you end up with an iterable
that's going to output collated batches, ready
for training.
Note that all of our collators take a return_tensors
argument - you can set this to "pt" to get
PyTorch Tensors, "tf" to get TensorFlow Tensors,
or "np" to get Numpy arrays.
For backward compatibility reasons, the default
value is "pt", so PyTorch users don't even
have to set this argument most of the time,
and so are often totally unaware that this
option exists.
This is a valuable lesson about how the beneficiaries
of privilege are often the most blind to its
existence.
So now let's see some specific DataCollators
in action, though remember that if none of
them do what you need, you can always write
your own!
First, we'll see the "basic" data collators.
These are DefaultDataCollator and DataCollatorWithPadding.
These are the ones you should use if your
labels are straightforward and your data doesn't
need any special processing before being ready
for training.
Most sequence classification tasks, for example,
would use one of these data collators.
Remember that because different models have
different padding tokens, DataCollatorWithPadding
will need your model's Tokenizer so it knows
how to pad sequences properly!
So how do you choose one of these?
Simple: As you can see here, if you have variable
sequence lengths then you should use DataCollatorWithPadding,
which will pad all your sequences to the same
length.
If you're sure all your sequences are the
same length then you can use the even simpler
DefaultDataCollator, but it'll give you an
error if that assumption is wrong!
Moving on, though, many of the other data
collators are often designed to handle one
specific task, and that's the case with DataCollatorForTokenClassification
and DataCollatorForSeqToSeq.
These tasks need special collators because
the labels are variable in length.
In token classification there's one label
for each token, and that means the length
of the labels can be variable, while in SeqToSeq
the labels are also a sequence of tokens that
can have variable length.
In both of these cases, we handle that by
padding the labels too, as you can see here.
Inputs and the labels will need to be padded
if we want to join samples of variable length
into the same minibatch, and that's exactly
what the data collators will do.
The final data collator I want to show you
is the DataCollatorForLanguageModeling.
It's very important, firstly because language
models are so foundational to everything we
do in NLP, and secondly because it has two
modes that do two very different things.
You choose which mode you want with the mlm
argument - set it to True for masked language
modeling, and False for causal language modeling.
Collating data for causal language modeling
is actually quite straightforward - the model
is just making predictions for what token
comes next, so your labels are more or less
just a copy of your inputs, and the collator
handles that and ensures your inputs and labels
are padded correctly.
When you set mlm to True, though, you get
quite different behaviour!
That's because masked language modeling requires
the labels to be, well... masked.
So what does that look like?
Recall that in masked language modeling, the
model is not predicting "the next word"; instead
we randomly mask out multiple tokens and the
model makes predictions for all of them at
once.
The process of random masking is surprisingly
complex, though - that's because if we follow
the protocol from the original BERT paper,
we need to replace some tokens with a masking
token, other tokens with a random token and
then keep a third set of tokens unchanged.
This isn't the lecture to go into *why* we
do that - you should check out the original
BERT paper if you're curious.
The main thing to know here is that it can
be a real pain to implement yourself, but
DataCollatorForLanguageModeling will do it
for you.
And that's it!
That covers the most commonly used data collators
and the tasks they're used for.